[Musique]
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre
le vide comme on reste auxerre
aujourd'hui ça va être saint pierre je
fais griller pour toi devant toi
maintenant promenade sur la plage ça
c'est la normandie voilà il plus un
petit peu des petit hôtel avec feu de
cheminée une bonne série
j'ai fait un petit soin visage du
magnifique un petit massage
j'adore à mon bonheur est à 9 sur 10 là
je vous dis
on veut bien entendre avec le logo
oui mais si on regarde ces cellules
instagram
aujourd'hui je suis avec m notre amie
charlotte
qu'est ce qu'on va faire charles à tout
le week-end ensemble il va être tout le
week-end on va présenter les missions
des mandragores ce soir on est au casino
d'enghien demain à chennevières sur
marne et ensuite on sera aux jeunes
thons bonites homologue son mac
le ton monte oh la la
bah oui bah huit rencontres
une personne est dans les bras là
[Musique]
cette vente est brossé son bord alors
non seulement ils sont beaux mais en
plus ils ont des vertus magnétique
antistress anti douleurs musculaires et
anti stress et améliore le sommeil parce
que toutes les petites manches à une je
peux dans le fruit
c'est quoi
[Musique]
je commençais tout est installé
là on est en pleine répète et lie à
charlotte charlotte veut bien nous
présenter les danseurs bien sûr c'est le
golan jeudi un salut quel programme
et maintenant on va danser maintenant
l'annoncé let's go
à partir de cette veste et qui brille et
cette chevelure de rêve
regardez ça cet horaire waouh et à qui
appartiennent ces tenues je me mette en
noir rouge et noir noir et noir tel est
mon dock est bien celui-là pas réservé
ce soir fouquet's qui est fouquet's et
oui mais là pas un bouc est à madiun
fouquet's et un samedi soir ça va être
blindé face à vannes pourra pas
s'asseoir ou pas on sait être un bon
buffard en dose de l année par les
petits vous avez vous éclater je vous
embrasse moi coucou tout le monde donc
je suis actuellement avec anita est on
en train de découvrir un petit lisseur
juste génial vous voyez il n'y a pas de
fil
enfin c'est trop cool ça veut dire que
vous n'êtes pas obligé de le brancher
galéré trouver un miroir faut qu'on
mette à genoux
[Musique]
jda avait promis des choses à voir